that's you blew the last guys yeah
that's that is that's nasty that's very
hard to deal with torn ACL MCL meniscus
god dude yeah so we go against Mikey
you're out of here
yeah
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
I'm wearing a white shirt for this [__]
very special guests couple special
guests yes you go ahead and you know I I
don't want to butcher your last name
because you're a mogul and you could
have me killed people
for people watching uh chatri who is the
owner and uh president of one founder of
One champion over there is Mikey who and
I told you this off there is you I my
piecing cues you gotta watch your PC
don't even bring up your [__] to around
him dude I don't I don't don't tell us
about the time you got a blue belt or
wrestled in high school wait or what
were the times is it the time where I
asked Sugar Ray Leonard how to go to the
body I asked him a boxing question and
he was like do you I can't I keep
getting hit when I turn this way and
he's like he literally went like this
he's teaching me and he goes he stopped
and he went it's on camera he goes we'll
work it we'll figure it out it was in
Sylvester one's house he goes we'll
we'll do this again we'll figure it out
he just realized what the [__] am I
doing
Hector who's
my boxer and I threw up in my mouth
I have to do that because I knew that
would kill you but let me just fill you
in please you know please so Chacha real
quick I need you to understand how he's
different I'm already annoying you no no
no no no
noises I don't think the majority of
audience understand what you're dealing
with now a guy like Chacha and Mikey I
agree let me start with Chachi and I'll
get the Mikey yeah the Chachi you're
talking about a guy Harvard educated yes
Harvest son of a [__] yes Harvard
educated no money you're [__]
Americans there's nothing Arvid Harvard
educated right came here with nothing
that's right him and his mom live in a
room now he runs a billion dollar
business well there's two players
there's two players in the world the UFC
and one championship and I believe one
Championship might be globally as big no
according to know our viewership numbers
are bigger than that see how I set him
up for that because I know that see how
I do that
softball's up because you're not
bragging but I gotta make it I gotta
make it come out of it you know
professionals professionals man yeah and
we'll get into what makes one
Championship different than the other
organizations I'll put you on game on
that but the audience needs to know with
chachi's background and going to Harvard
and you know being an immigrant and
American living the actual American
dream and going from Harvard with his
one suitcase with everything he has you
know providing for his family one meal a
day nuts too
it's hardcore and and also the fact that
you've been a lifelong martial arts yeah
Muay Thai and Jiu Jitsu and I I I don't
know how you do this but you do it every
day pretty much right yeah every day but
but this is the difference like and this
isn't a knock on any other owners of
organizations fight organizations but it
you run circles around them when you
think about their education their
perspective as far as martial arts it's
not even close my man
that's fair to say yeah I'd love to do
that debate if anyone wants to debate
that yeah
I I never looked at it the way I just
look at it like I love martial arts I've
been doing my whole life and I'm just a
lucky lucky guy to be able to do what I
do I'm just very lucky yeah yeah and it
seems like you're doing it for the right
reasons where a lot of people look at it
from a business aspect which obviously
you want business to go well so you can
continue to put on great fights but
you're not a guy who let's say Amazon
came to you at the end of your contract
I think in four years and goes all right
well we love it we'll take it you're not
a guy who's looking to just sell yeah no
yeah Ariel asked me that the other day
and I said there's no way I'm not here
if money was the motivation then I would
have sold this a long time ago it was
great Ariel was so good Ariel was so
good in that interview because he's like
come on all the hassle and you're like I
love it there's like nine billion
dollars right off in the sunset and you
were like I'm not a kid because you just
love it so much it's more of a yeah it
really is it's 24 7 Obsession wow that's
what it is and what what what are you
doing here with Mikey well Mikey's real
quick I fill in some of it Mikey's the
co-main event on the fight card uh May
5th correct May 5th in my hometown to
Denver Colorado Mikey is a co-main event
no pressure Mike I didn't know you were
doing it I'm sorry that I'm ignorant I
thought you were strictly jiu jitsu
do you want to hit him or should I so
they and they took him out one
Championship does I like that so real
quick oh you got the defense yeah oh
deadly I think you're dealing with
so real quick in one Championship they
do Muay Thai
that's where Rod tank comes from right
Muay Thai who's the Savage over there
they do Jiu Jitsu I didn't know they do
MMA yeah
so he's the co-main event
as a jiu jitsu player which is a lot of
pressure because the MMA audience right
sometimes any fight any organization
goes to the floor like oh come on man so
with him there's a lot of pressure to
make it exciting because yes for jujitsu
today it can be the way Jiu Jitsu is
going I'm not knocking on Jutsu but it
can get a little boring we're starting
their butt stuff like that so that's why
he has all the pressure but you have a
good opponent who's gonna make it
decided yes definitely
but we have to make it exciting for
people that don't know what Jiu Jitsu is
that they can watch it and enjoy it yeah
you're you're a savant though your
ability so I thought about you because
Josh Wade skin I don't know if you know
Josh waitskin he's a Marcelo Garcia
black belt he's a chess master and he
wrote a book called the art of learning
and so Josh can play
um he got obsessed when he kind of
mastered chess so he'd be the guy who
he'd Play 50 really good players at a
time and beat them all it's like how
does he do that and he was equating it
with Jujitsu well he he he's able to
chunk information so he can look at a
board and he sees the board he goes I've
seen that a thousand times I've seen
that a million times so I know
everything you're about to do and I can
it's not that he's thinking five moves
ahead he just knows what you're gonna do
and he can so he can chunk information
and and he was kind of drawing
comparisons to jiu jitsu and kind of
studying Marcelo Garcia but it feels can
you kind of explain how you see yeah
because you're such a project I'm always
fascinated with because I know you're
you're seeing things differently it's
like you're speaking Japanese and
everybody else is speaking French right
you know what I'm saying like it feels
like you're you're able to see someone's
game be like right away and break it
down is that is that how it works yeah
so it's just like chess basically you
have your line of attacks and you know
every single reaction the person is
going to give you and you have an answer
to every reaction so it's basically a
chess board so you're ahead all the time
always like like 20 moves ahead and you
you started at one age four years old
four four years old so those neural
pathways are so my son's sorry my son
started at six damn it hey boss
that's like tennis like tennis there was
an 11 year old Champion she was the
national champion in tennis and they
were like it's too late I said what are
you talking about I was watching our
Pleasures her stroke she grooved stroke
wrong so I don't think we can get it I
was like she's 11. like I know but when
you started at four did they see were
you an outlier even at four we're like
oh this kid
um I don't even know if I was such an
outlier until I was like 10 years old
because I was always scared to compete
really yeah so I didn't compete much as
a young kid until like 10 years old what
clicked
I just I wanted to break my fear of
competing so I just kept going and I
would be scared I would be scared and
then I started loving competing and was
you did your parents push you to compete
or who no honestly my parents didn't
even push me to train at all and I feel
like that's why I stuck to it I feel
like if they would have told me you have
to train I would have ended up quitting
yeah because kids don't want to do what
their parents tell them right exactly so
I feel like because they didn't tell me
to train I just wanted to myself yeah
and then uh going through high school
and everything were people aware of how
good you were at Jiu Jitsu in school I
didn't talk much as a kid I just stayed
like I was in the back of the room with
headphones on and I'll get my grades
yeah good grades yeah always yeah and
then I would just go train all day geez
nuts yeah B let's take a little break
here because UFC 288 is here this
Saturday Al Joe Versus Henry sahudo the
ban weight title is on the line we're
doing a cow pass fight Japan 7 P.M
Pacific live on thick boy YouTube with
the great Ryan Garcia coming off his
record set thing gate over there in Las
Vegas against Devonte Davis and they
also have George Janko and a very
special guest but if you want to watch
fight companion you want to watch UFC
288 do it and make bank with draftking
Sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of the UFC new customers can
make a five dollar bet and score 150 in
bonus bets instantly
everyone can take everyone can take the
MMA action on the next level the
DraftKings same game parlay combined
multiple bets for a shot at even bigger
payout I like all the dogs
chances of all of them winning are not
good but I like Chrome Gracie I like
Muhammad and I like Al Joe and then also
toss in Matt Steamroller in there as
well they're all dogs that parlay is
going to pay some bankaroos download the
DraftKings Sportsbook app right now use
code fighter you bet five dollars on any
UFC 288 fight and get 150 in bonus bets
instantly this Saturday on draftking
Sportsbook with a code fighter gambling
problem called 1-800 gambler
three two seven five fifty fifty or
visit gambling helpline
ma.org in New York call 8778 Hope NY or
text Hope and why 467-369 in Kansas call
1-800-522-4700 on behalf of Boot Hill
Casino and Resort Kansas 21 and over in
most eligible Statesman age varies by
jurisdiction eligibility restrictions
apply C notes for offer details see
draftkings.com Sportsbook for details
and stay specific reasonable gambling
resources DraftKings promo code fighter
I had a party this weekend Brandon
you'll a party and I uh take some nuts I
took the old house of macadamia nuts and
threw them in a boat were they the head
of the party well I had the white
chocolate covered I had the regular
chocolate covered I go for those first I
had the raspberry uh uh chocolate
vanilla covers unbelievable I had the
Cracked Pepper they got all different
ones people are popping nuts woofed them
down including my 15 month old he went
hey I got a taste for expensive nuts I
was like take it easy kid that's too
expensive but then I remembered House of
macadamia oh they're fantastic these
nuts affordable they are the best nut
for you literally macadamias are rich in
omega-7 fatty acids with support
stabilized blood glucose levels and
satiety so you feel Fuller for longer
and are less likely that's why they say
macadamia nuts are possibly the best nut
for fat loss as well as the best tasting
yes me they used to be just for the rich
I play tennis not anymore listen to me
listen to me world record epigenetic Age
reducer Ryan Johnson includes macadamias
in his daily blueprint diet all right
the omega-7 fatty acids in macadamias
are also they've also been linked to
collagen production and reducing
inflammation key parts of longevity uh
and I don't eat them for any other
reason than the fact that they're
delicious also the the brand House of
macadamias a brand is farmer owned they
can always guarantee the best quality
and prices no sugar added or artificial
ingredients all right they even have
cold pressed extra virgin macadamia oil
with buttery flavor all right
um listen they don't do discounts but
for you guys they're gonna do it all
right house of macadamias has a very
special offer use code tfak for 20 off
your order for a limit time they're
giving you guys a free bottle of cold
press extra virgin Macadamia Oil worth
20 buckaroos so grease up your friends
suck on some nuts when you visit House
of macadamias.com
tfak House of macadamia you can grease
yourself over extraversion macadamia nut
oil I recommend it but you can also
ingest it and it's better for you by
many measures according to a lot of
studies get naughty dude olive oil dude
I'm not in your mouth right now no no no
thanks I got enough with House of
macadamia and that's disgusting
foreign
that's how it's supposed to look yeah
like people get confused this day and
age you see these big guys and Jack
dudes like that's not really what juice
do is made for he's made for the smaller
man defend himself against the bigger
guy right right and you know he also
trains Mark Zuckerberg you son of a
[__]
sorry guys
he's really into it yeah yeah he's
awesome and he's like my size also and
he has a lot of potential does he yeah
he's only been training a year and a
half and he's already decent like he's
amazing yeah he's taking privates from
you it's not like yeah
he's learned off the fat black belt off
Ventura here he's learning from you and
do you fly to his house too or did you
have the Facebook offices I went to his
house and we trained does he give you
like a million dollars an hour
let me keep doing this I need five
million now
give me one million dollars immediately
because she can it's not good yeah but
but he's he's decent at Jitsu he's
decent you know and he loves it like
he's very passionate about it so it's
really cool and so cool like how Jiu
Jitsu could bring everyone together yeah
again because a guy like Mark Zuckerberg
he's he's not gonna kind of get
gravitate towards boxing or kickboxing
like you look at him right he actually
he likes Muay Thai as well it doesn't
hurt yeah so that's what he loves him we
were doing Muay Thai together too oh
damn it was a fencer for a long time so
he loves that whole Space yeah yeah yeah
fencing Muay Thai but he is obsessed
with fence but Chacha it's a risk for
you to putting a jiu jitsu as a co-main
event on a big big card like this I need
to put more pressure on him in front of
him you know somebody saw her when she
was in here to answer but you know it's
like a lot of pressure because yeah you
know there's a lot riding on this as far
as the event just as a whole because
there's so much Legacy in history with
Denver mixed martial arts yep and you're
putting Jiu Jitsu as the co-main event
yes yes and the main event's a big deal
yeah I mean you know whenever a fighter
talks about time I always get a little
bit worried but you know DJ obviously is
the goat so I won't get too worried but
he's he said it's it's probably going to
be his last fight I don't I mean I think
it's good I mean it's he says that but
some apartment he's like nah that's good
you're right because he hasn't he hasn't
missed a beat in fact he's gotten better
so good he's got so good nothing to the
though is he might be feeling like I
want to leave at the Apex no one ever
does no one ever spoils off into the
sunset you know GSP yep but it's very
rare that that we all go more almost
always with Fighters we're like number
GSB at the war with Johnny Hendricks yes
and was like forget it couldn't see out
of his eyes no and he was like oh this
guy I'm good right yeah with Mighty
Mouse too it's not like the fight with
him Marias it's not like you know it's
their third fight and it's one and one
but it's not like the first fight like
they walk through each other the second
fight yeah yeah fight fight like the
fight these guys are feeding that last
one these two guys are the very best
flyaways on the planet full stop I mean
you just look technically and and I was
saying to Ariel look you know when I was
on a show a bunch of medium results like
maybe it wasn't him it was another one I
was that if you strip away all the
credentials and all the achievements and
you just look purely from a martial arts
perspective
what are their skill sets of striking
what are their skill sets and grappling
what are the skill sets on wrestling
cage control uh transitions Etc
you look at that and they say okay
that's great then you look at their
athletic uh the athleticism their car to
explosive balance their speed their
ability to put to get their fight IQ
it's just off the charts it's off the
charts and that's what makes and then
you add in the layers of who they fought
and how many times they've defended
their titles and it's literally the two
greatest flyers on the planet in history
the thing is what I'm excited about one
coming here is I want to see I'm very
curious to see you've got these monsters
you've got some sick Russian wrestlers
you've got crazy strikers yes and the
UFC is good at making Stars well we when
we think about MMA we think UFC but I I
have to believe you're going to have
some some charismatic killers and people
who seem to look like they read books
and are absolute Wizards and people in
this country are gonna love it so you're
gonna be making Stars this is why
they're gonna love it because if you
look at the Finish like in America
especially like we like finishes yes
like they don't like technical their
rules are different the rules are
different but also the Finish rates way
more than double
compared to 30 on the ground right can't
you need one yes sir yep that's how DJ
lost his first fight yep yeah that's a
whole different game yeah because
there's no more lay in prayer because
even if you're on top and side control
the guy can need you in the face right
so you have to be active and and that's
what again but you know the at the root
of it okay the DNA ethos of one is very
different from anything that exists in
the world today and and it's such a
unique differentiated
um experience for the fans because you
know why was martial arts invented okay
five thousand years ago a birthplace of
martial arts in Asia it's not to do
Pitter pattering and and and gamify and
do a double leg take down the end of 10
seconds and then I win 10-9 and you
could do that three times and you win
the fight that's not a fight that's like
hiding secret tag right that's there's a
rule and there's a physical activity
right now
when martial arts was first invented and
created
it's to finish a fight it's that's it's
because it's a self-defense someone's
coming to your house I'm gonna mug you
rob you or hurt you all right and so
you're not going to be like okay you
know what let me jab this guy one two
for three minutes and then you're like
no I'm gonna finish this and I think
that is one big part of and of course
you know our team does a great job in
finding these killers that have that
killer instinct of finishing fights
um but that you know at root I think
that is also and then obviously the the
global rule set lends itself to it and
the fact that it scored in one round the
entire fight is scored as if it's one
giant round you see the 10-90 can you
explain that yeah it's a 10 must system
I just explained if you do a double leg
takeout down let's say the fight's
pretty even you do a double leg take
down at the end of 10 seconds at a 10
second Mark of every round you win the
fight you basically win the fight but
that's not to me that's not fighting
right that's not fighting but you do see
that a lot uh because of the unified
rule system now a when you score the
fight it's an entirety it's exactly like
you see a street fight okay if I'm
nailing you with one Twos for three
minutes straight and you nail that one
and then five seconds left there's no
time but you smack me with the overhand
right left hook and I'm wobbled and my
friends have to jump in and stop
I want to fight do you want to fight
it's very clear that is it so under that
we've been talking about that a lot
because in the UFC you see the guy will
win two rounds but then the other guy
dominates the third round and though the
question was always for guys like me who
watch her you know just fans I go I feel
like that round should be scored higher
than the other two but of course
boxing's not and stuff like that but
that makes so much more sense that's
exactly so when you score like that see
you know let's say you're dominating me
for the full fight and this is in one I
know that up until the last second if I
hurt you because the scoring criteria in
the global rules system is obviously
it's KO and finish after that it's near
KO and finish near KO near near
submission and then after that's damage
it's a real fight it's so the whole
construct of one exciting yeah it's just
different yeah so you know at the very
it could be at the very last second and
and the fight's super close or the guys
dominate with one twos and you're not
that hurt and you clock him hard and
he's wobbling here she's about to go go
out yeah
you want to fight it's an easy concept I
think for people to understand too even
though it's gonna be a little different
for the United States fan base they're
gonna be able to understand that it
makes sense are you 100 it makes a lot
more are you worried about the
Commission in uh Colorado getting that
right because they're so used to score
it the other way no so we did we've
taken our time luckily you know we were
supposed to enter to the U.S in 2020
before cover hit and so we've had and
our us team has had a lot of time
talking to all the athletic commissions
around the around the country educating
them and of course Colorado was the most
welcoming and most aggressive of all the
athletic Commissions in terms of wanting
one here and so there's a long this is
not like we planned this in two months
no this has been you know three years in
the making four years in the making in
terms of uh making sure that we get it
right because again
Americans are so used to
um the unified rule set versus the
global rule set yes and each has its
strengths and weaknesses but we really
truly believe that you know the reason
why one has a 70 finish rate and these
are the best martial arts on the planet
it's not like you know uh it is the
Adriana morize of the world but it's
because the incentive structure is very
different you know there's nothing more
uh uh disheartening than a guy laying
praying you and and you know every the
last 10 seconds every round just holding
you down and you just lost a fight right
it's it's so again I think what has
happened is
we've lost the essence of martial arts
and that's what I think we're gonna
that's why American fans are going to be
blown away it's like here you're going
to get real fighting across multiple
disciplines killers and Monsters the
very best of the best in the planet like
Mikey he's you know
these guys come to finish his submission
right I mean so it's everything very
interesting how this changes the UFC how
how do you have C reaction to this but I
guess my question Joshua for you and I
get one for you Michael my coach for you
is who cares about America I know it's
the biggest as far as we're the biggest
Sports kind of consumers but you guys
are crushing it everywhere else yeah do
you feel like you have to take over the
American Market you know like I think of
course for sure because first of all the
U.S market especially the sports Market
is the largest in the world okay by far
and by far by far I think it's like 80
of revenues of sports it comes in
America more than China right now but
now of course you're gonna have to look
at the future yes right I mean up until
this point U.S has the Giant Sports
properties NFL's worth 100 billion NBA's
70 billion you know the MLB NASCAR blah
blah blah blah blah
um and and there the modernization here
is massive it's just massive and even
just looking at our Amazon partnership
right you know the the they Amazon spent
11 billion dollars for Thursday Night
Football it's a different level of
Commerce yeah and Americans just
absolutely love sports and so for us
like to be a truly Global property we
felt like look America is an important
critical Market to win
um and and and you know it's the first
time of course that a Asian property is
coming and entering into America
normally it's the other way around like
it's NBA going to China or the other so
this is the first time in history that a
global Sports property from Asia is
coming into America
um and I I'm telling we're bringing the
entire world of martial arts the best of
the best across all the disciplines to
American fans and they're going to be
blown away you'll see I think they'll be
blown away obviously by the temple but I
think they'll be blown away I think
where the Special Sauce lies is with you
chocolate ah come on I'm
yeah because if you look at like the
other guys I'm not calling anybody out
but you look at the other owners of
organizations not just UFC or Bellator
or pfl if you look at NBA NFL their
story isn't it's not your your story is
so unique that most Americans especially
the immigrants in America can relate to
so people are going to root for for you
no thank you thank you thank you martial
arts so much even in between an event we
would be training like he'll be like hey
you want to train and during in the
middle that's why
yeah Mark Zuckerberg going around but
your your town pool there is a
significant there is a difference it
used to be that UFC has the elite of the
elite because that's where you go for
all the money and the attention and I'm
not saying that Bellator doesn't have
Killers they've got Killers but for the
most part at least up until very
recently the UFC was sort of like the
major league so I so I beg to differ I I
again and I'm speaking as a lifelong
martial artist and as an educated uh uh
person yes when you look skill set to
skill set and you really drill deep
heavyweight division down Champion
versus champion and you look like you
know I think it's 50 50. one one versus
one versus that's what I'm talking about
the the only pushback I'd have there
touching you know I love you man my
Molly push pushback would be when it
comes to the heavyweights from from one
to Fifteen yes the the depth in the UFC
because yes the reason that UFC so
um why they have a monopoly on the
market in the United States is it it's
the depth yes at every weight class one
through fifteen even at the last
spiderweights one through fifty it's
pretty stacked yes and especially the
heavyweight yeah so I I would yeah of
course because you know in the states
there are a lot more 255 250 pounds
right than they are than they are in
Asia
um but
um there's one heavyweight that I think
is I genuinely think he's the best
heavier on the planet on a roster
Anatoly malikin okay listen to his
pedigree National wrestling he's 12-0
80 90 finish rate one punch KO power and
there you go and he was on the national
wrestling team in Russia okay okay and
you talk you talk to anybody on the
Russian national debt this guy is a real
deal and then when you see him move he
moves like like a uh you know a
middleweight but he hits like a truck I
mean I'm seriously he hits like a truck
yeah and he's very very fast I thought
RDR was gonna beat him yeah so that so I
you know I had a big question mark I
thought if RDR could take him down but
then you saw the world-class Russian
wrestling yes did you see so I don't
know if you there's one where where's
yes where Anatoly throws a right hand or
even a left hook Mrs whiffs and articles
under it gets the hips
no no but I mean RDR is one of my
favorites yeah but the the way he shot
that that Russian wrestling system is
yeah
well this is a great segue my question I
mean we can find out who's the best you
could sign Francis what's up bro
um I'm meeting friends tomorrow France
is gonna have a hard time dealing with
those that level of wrestling yeah I
think so I so look you can find out I
have a lot of respect for France I think
he's done amazing things and obviously
you know uh he was a a great heavyweight
champion for UFC but I I do think that
there are still holes in his game uh
right so so so he does have one punch
kale power but so does Anatoly uh but
then you have analog's wrestling that's
truly world class you're not gonna stop
it and if you look at jujuts and I'm
gonna I'm gonna speak purely from a jiu
jitsu lens here
Francis and ganu's Jiu Jitsu is very
lacking it's just it's just not world
class right so same level as Mark
Zuckerberg probably
right Mikey
Zuckerberg said is here right now he's
from a helicopter say it say say it bad
thing see what happens he just
disappears into the metaverse you know
and that's what I mean you know
um if also I'd love American fans if you
just step away from all the rhetoric in
the market you know every organization
is going to have its own marketing I try
my best to sign the very best when I
look at them across you know all the
divisions all the disciplines I look at
from a purist perspective how good are
they technically how good I do I think
they can be technically in the future
how what do they bring to the table in
terms of raw genetic athleticism raw
cardio uh genetic you know all the
different attributes that make Superstar
athletes um and then you put that all
together and then like you know and
that's why again when we signed DJ
um I was so fired up because beyond the
whole he did that he had the most title
defenses in the UFC and blah blah blah
blah I knew as a martial artist that
this guy has everything everything the
way he moves between you know the the
different martial arts is just
unbelievable and I think with going back
to Francis I think what would be
appealing to France is not only could he
compete mixed martial arts at the
highest level but you also allow them to
box yes and you guys have done that
before yes exactly so that's why I think
again from France he might have a tough
run at in in one in MMA I don't know if
he can win the title genuinely I don't I
I think it's probably going to be
difficult for him but I think he can box
and potentially win a world I think he
can you know
um kickbox you can do it he can do
different things right
um that will allow him to to express his
full athletic potential I just don't
know if if uh yeah if he can handle the
you know our heavyweight division I'd
like to see and he might like the
challenge though but maybe that's that's
challenge he's looking for I think
that's what he's looking for but I think
he's looking for that I don't interrupt
you I think he's looking for that but I
also think he is looking for that big
boxing payday fight which you guys yes
we can go promote with him and it's also
it's not like you you'd be changing the
rules over Francis you guys have done
before and you're badass what is your
middleweight uh solich the croatians
hold it yeah
monsters and he wants to be uh Champion
boxing kickboxing and MMS like that's
why I signed with one Championship so
it's not like you're giving special
treatment to Francis no no no no and
when you hear about it no no Francis
don't know it no that guy Mikey wants to
do MMA Mikey Martin so we are very
flexible you see the point is that you
should ex you be able as a martial
artist you should be able to express
yourself how you want to okay and create
your own legacy if you're a JuJu guy
there's no there's no issue Kate and Ty
they both want to do MMA as well they
want to leave their mark on MMA amazing
so you can be a multiple a sport title
holder world champion and that's the
platform at one so Francis could end up
being a boxing WBC boxing world champion
if he ever got a shot at whoever let's
say you know um Deontay Wilder yeah
whatever it is right right and it would
be held in on the one platform or if he
said hey I want to do I want to try
every kickboxing Etc
um so I think there's a real challenge
for for France we're definitely pay the
most money okay that that's the money is
not where I'm I'm concerned about I'm
concerned about is Francis the other
other stuff that he has in mind and the
other stuff we have in mind do they jive
and also is it a line yeah it's a line
you have to have the same kind of vision
and values of uh if you want to um do
work together right it's just common
sense so have you ever have you rolled
with these Russian Superstar wrestlers
have you done anything yeah and it
totally am eviled a little bit is that
true yes well that's that's about like
three minutes that's a fair three
minutes that's a dog versus a bear you
know what I mean that's a Silverback
you're messing he's still big yeah what
was that like that must have been
horrifying but uh was it just wrestling
the whole time so we were okay who's it
just wrestling though no we were just
like moving around like having okay
because here's the thing yeah it's a dog
for spear but that dog has some ankle
attacks that Bear's never seen oh ankles
I always forget about the old ankies
because you can't your ankles your
ankles yeah that's you blew the last
guys yeah that's that is that's nasty
that's very hard to deal with torn AC
MCL meniscus god dude yeah so when you
go against Mikey you're out of here
you've got to tap in me yeah yeah you're
out of here yeah this kid is Roberto
this guy so he literally problems this
kid's so good wait wait wait he's uh
welterweight
yeah he
um
let me tell you about Roberto come
RoboCop by the way yeah RoboCop yeah
[Applause]
um
he's one of those once in a in a
generation kind of athlete and this is
what I mean I look at world champions
all day I get to look at all the very
best athletes on the planet you know
free agent when he came out when he came
to free agency he obviously got a huge
offer from uh UFC a huge offer not not
the typical 10 and 10 or whatever it is
he got a huge offer
um he got an offer from Belgium and we
obviously gave a big offer but before we
did
I said hey Roberto come come to
Singapore I want to see how good you are
I want to see he starts training Jiu
Jitsu wrestling and hitting the pads and
stuff and I look at him I'm like oh I
mean I was blown away this guy that good
huh because his I mean I've never seen
one punch kale power like the other side
I got his size he's a little bit bigger
than me a little bit not not much but he
he hit like as if he would wait 300
pounds and he like Mike Tyson like a
bomb it was like a rocket like boom boom
yeah just a special athlete and his
balance and his movement
um explosiveness and then
um then I was told I was like man this
guy of course he has like a 85 90 KO
rate uh you know 20 wins and it's just
crazy
so then I messaged GSP I'm like bro uh
Roberto's here right now what do you
think of him because they trained
together TriStar and Kim Jesus we were
like killer monster that's it she's like
killer yeah and then I've heard cosine
yeah yeah he was like he's like the guys
because he dominated everyone at TriStar
that you know this this is the damn the
talk that I get from the TriStar guys he
came in and dominate everybody everybody
what was his how did art what do you
mean start what was his where he comes
yeah he's from a little town actually in
Bosnia but yes he's Croatian
um in a tiny little village
and uh you want to do MMA and so there
was one guy that he knew from a guy a
friend of a friend of a friend named
Yvonne
um uh Djokovic who lived in uh Germany
and Dusseldorf and they talk talk and I
think at the time Roberto was like 17
years old
and uh he's like okay can I come he's
like okay come you know I have a room
for you everything
he gets a Dusseldorf
Waits at the bus stop where he's
supposed to meet Yvonne and Yvonne fully
forgot so it's like four hours later
he's seeing that and and then Roberto's
like man I'm gonna get kidnapped I don't
speak the language you know it's German
I don't know where I am and it's getting
dark and like the dude doesn't just
disappear he told me you know I travel
whatever 12 hours to get here
then Yvonne shows up by the way they
both tell me this story because they're
they're best best buddies now Yvonne
shows up and goes okay come on let's go
I'll get you a room he goes to the gym
and this is gonna be real they open the
uh the the the the you know cleaning
closet it's got like you know the
janitorial supplies you know the broom
and then he takes it goes like this
we're gonna sleep
and Roberto's like he had this
imagination of you know the guys
apartment you know like it's gonna be
like so he slept at the gym and and and
he he said he didn't speak language he
didn't have money for food he was like
frightened he's like charity all I did
was like like I didn't know what to do
and I didn't so all I said was slip down
and trained all day long and I said and
then then Yvonne would start putting him
on the local Circle and he just blew
everyone out he just blew knocked
everyone out I love those Origins series
and uh and then so I actually was so so
when we signed him I actually went to uh
Croatia I went to uh Zagreb so I'm in
Zagreb uh with Roberto and Ivan we're
they're doing a press conference of uh
we were announcing his uh his signing
and um well I know we were at lunch and
then suddenly um uh
um Roberto gets a message from quilcop
miracle
hey I heard trash in town uh tell him to
come to my house now let's go and then I
tried to your friend like yeah okay
we'll go hang on oh yeah sure that's
cool I go I love cocoa because if I go
in this first time I ever meet him right
he's nice great nicest guy ever he
hasn't lost and yeah his body fat
percentage is still I don't know like
five percent these Jacks She's Fit he
trains still three four hours a day okay
still so we're talking having fun and
it's and Crow cops mom is giving us tea
it's like almost surreal right so I'm
here I mean Instagram and then cook
upset hey chatri I have a uh my gym
downstairs let's start training so I'm
thinking okay he's gonna do like like
just nice easy technique or whatever
because he's huge he's 250 I'm only 180.
um and then and then Roberto's like no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
so we all go down there and uh uh
Miracle's like okay let me just show you
this is my high kick you know his famous
high kick so he's like and this guy like
I gotta you know crocop is just a very
fun passionate person yeah so and he
doesn't understand how strong he is so
he's like okay let me show you oh sorry
come on oh boy put me inside control
come on hold me tight hold me tight and
he does this like crazy like
oh my God you said that he was the
strongest guy you ever oh he's so strong
he's freakishly strong freakish yeah and
and then so and Roberto's like hey
miracle miracle this is he's not he's
not fighting you know this is
let me show you mine and I'm like so we
end up beer there for an hour and a half
two hours training experience though
yeah no it was amazing it was surreal
but I mean but also but take it easy but
but eventually like like you know it'll
end up being like a full-on training
you know you're like I have some tea
yeah I'm having tea from his mom did you
guys eat or just tea no no we no we had
dinner afterwards and it was all meat
like a miracle style
yes that's it that's what they're doing
to grab it and he's like Tom Cruise out
there right yeah oh he's a god he's a
God so he we're sitting there first of
all we get to the restaurant and again
I'm thinking like that this is such I'm
having dinner unplanned after just
training for a couple hours with with uh
with with these guys I'm hungry we walk
into this restaurant it's only red meat
like only I love it like nothing else
part of the world no so I think okay we
sit down and he's like a god I mean
America is a God okay in Croatia so he
everyone's like oh my God I'm taking
pictures
Etc and then this huge it's like it's
like the ancient time there's a huge
plate of meat like it's like
[Music]
and all kinds of meat and then like
again so I felt like it was like you
know I don't know one of these like
English Empire roles yeah
yeah
it's a fight to the death I have so many
of these funny crazy stories on this
last 11 years of you know building one
starting in building one it's just like
but I I find myself in these random
situations like I'm like how the hell
but what a life it's but it's so fun
yeah build this because you know at the
end of the day for me it was like I was
a kid in a candy store I I'm a lifelong
martial artist so for me to be
experiencing this it's just it's wild
you know it's like it just
started like you you go to Harvard what
did you study at Harvard business
business so you come out of you you got
no money you're with your mother your
dad left when you were a kid not a kid
but but
sad story man no no no it is a very sad
story and it did uh uh you know I had a
lot of anger in me for a long time was
it present as a father though no no no
no he was never present uh yeah so I
don't want to speak ill of him because
he's no longer here but but he was you
know what what I learned from that whole
experience is I'd rather remember the
good in people yeah you see he did many
things wrong but all of us you know
every human being you know we make
mistakes forgiveness man and and you got
to forgive and and so that for me is
like
um but then when I wrote down what the
things he gave me so after he passed
away
um that night I I went back and just
reflected on everything I'm like you
know I was speaking to him I was like
Dad you know I just want to say thank
you for everything and Etc et cetera you
know I know you screwed up here and
there but I wanna and I wrote down one
of the things that you know first of all
he gave me my name Chuck Tree in Thai
which means warrior in Thailand in Thai
in the Thai language
then at nine years old he took me to
lumpini Stadium which is the mecca of
Muay Thai for my first experience it's
like it's like in America taking your
kid to a ball game right you like going
to Lambeau Field yeah whatever it is
yeah so he introduced me and I fell
instantly in love with it then at 13
I've been I always want to trade my my
parents said no no wait wait until you
get a little bit bigger when I was 13
they finally said okay my dad said fine
you really launching let's go to City
Gym which was the number one
professional fighting gym at the time
legendary Right legendary so I go there
and my father takes me and then go and
so he interviewed me with Ty and then I
started writing all the good things he
did and then you balance it with the
path so again what I learned from that
experience is look people might do
[__] up [__] but but
especially find it find empathy in your
heart and compassion that you know
nobody's perfect and he had his issues
he had his own deals yeah
right didn't he create desperation too
because you had nothing so you had to
figure out a way to make no no so that's
also one of the things I was thanking
him for I said hey Dad you know like in
a way you abandoning the family you're
going bankrupt and abandoning the family
was a blessing for me because it taught
me that I have fireman it gave me fire
my belly right away because in Asian
culture okay it's very different than
American culture it's like the once the
patriarch leaves then the oldest son has
to be the patriarch I had to find a way
to figure out so I paid for my younger
brother's University school fees and
everything and his whole living expense
as well and my mother and all because
all the burn came on me and so you know
it that's just the way Asian culture is
or Thai culture and I said Dad thanks
because like if you never gave me that
experience then I wouldn't know how I
would have reacted so you know it's uh I
forget who said some great philosopher
said you know
um the unhappiest man is is the man
who's never uh allowed to test himself
yeah like if you never given the
opportunity to see how Nietzsche said
Nietzsche said if I ever have children I
I wish for them loss and privation and
suffering yes because it's it brings out
the best of who you are yes yeah and it
really does I mean I think that you know
it's it's like my friend was going
through some really really tough stuff
you know and he said uh I said man it's
tough he goes I know but only the
Blessed get to face this because if you
navigate it the right way you'll come
out a very different yes yeah for sure
but but so you your mother's still alive
yeah my mother uh she lives with me in
Singapore now because she's 70 75 years
old Mama we made it yeah
we made it
um I always say yeah I'd never there's
two reasons why I made it out of poverty
it's like one is the love of mother you
know my mom she just loved me and she
believed in me even when we're in in
that little tiny dorm room and
um in my very first startup we had
sleeping bags I couldn't afford a bed so
we had sleeping bags and slept on the
floor okay of the office that was and
then we ate a dollar fifty microwave uh
uh frozen food that was our and the fact
that my mom could do that with me like
you know she just believed in me and
that was my very first time here's my
point name another owner of any Sports
organization that has this backstory
Brian I love it man I love it I love
that story nuts and and then it's fun no
no I'm telling you I I this whole week
and even be with you Brendan man I'm a
big fan for a long time like it's just
surreal I'm not a fan of you but
guys rolled together
[Laughter]
so
thing okay it's been surreal for me
because I'll tell you why
I came at one point when I was in
America I had one suitcase with all my
life's belongings and if you said Josh
roll forward in your life you'll be back
to America and you're going to be coming
with a huge event with the best martial
art the greatest martial on the planet
right and you're gonna show and bring
the whole world of martial arts to
America and introduce it introduce
martial arts like I'm like man it's
never really and here's the other thing
I am so there's two feelings I have
deepened and I was telling Mikey this
earlier it's it's one of I feel it's
very everything's surreal but the other
one and more powerful is a deep sense of
gratitude I live the American dream only
you know and that's why America is one
of the greatest countries in the world
only only in America can you be a
nothing and a nobody but because you
work hard you do good you do right take
risks and you take risks yeah you can do
something in your life yeah yeah every
other country that I've ever been in you
just don't have that same I love that
you're saying this because people
nowadays bash this country and they
forget that it's still such a land of
opportunity and it's people like you who
come come here with a vision that kind
of energy that make this country great
it's and it's this it is the American
story it is so as old as this country
has been around yeah and that's yeah if
you think about there's only 335 million
people in America and and it's the
richest economy in the world 25 of
global GDP yeah how is it possible
there's eight billion people in the
world and there's there's just these 335
million people and they create literally
25 of the world's economy free
enterprise a marketplace right and and
it's it's the it's the whole Pursuit of
Happiness it's the individual you know
Pursuit and it's American dream so the
reason why I feel grateful is I live the
American dream it gave me it gave me
that incredible education and it got me
out of poverty Etc and having a
financial resources start one and then
for me to come back and literally
introduce the entire world of martial
arts to Americans it's just like dude
when you talk because I swear to God
when you talk you say he sounds like a
dude who's just starting like something
he's super excited about yeah
and I went to this concert and the guy
made a new car right in front of me like
this and I was freaking out it's like
hey bro you're a mogul yeah
the company for you're basically a
billionaire and he's like I'm in another
thing I love it it's like you sound like
you and you look about 23 years old no
I'm 52. are you dude 52 yeah
you guys
you look similar yeah no pressure no
pressure Mike you know it's like this
this co-main event on a massive and as
far as Jitsu goes how's it work uh if
you can speak out contractually are you
still allowed to compete in like the
other major tournaments and then still
represent one Championship or well the
thing is this is professional right like
what is why would I want to compete in
anything else this is the most
professional thing possible for jiu
jitsu and it keeps you active enough I
can compete I need every month if I
wanted to you know and one Championship
gives Jiu Jitsu this platform that we
never had you know so it's a huge
responsibility for me being on the face
of it brother you're the face of it and
I think more people will be able to
relate to a guy like you with your
stature than other guys who we know of
you know like people are like oh Mikey
can do this at that level and you're
getting belts winning World
Championships well inspiring others and
motivating others that's my whole goal
of competing still you know and it's a
huge responsibility but I'm blessed for
that opportunity I have and do you do
anything else besides just focus on Jiu
Jitsu right now not really you know
um just learning in other aspects of
life like to be a better person
um learning a little business too I
always ask him questions yeah I would
ask him all the questions every second
that's a smart guy yeah I mean that's an
education in itself while you're rolling
as you're putting in a choke so um if
you're how do you do marketing you know
between Joshua and Mark Zuckerberg I
think it'd be all right
that's a crazy forget money just have
them teach you when you start jits you
ever think you'd lead you down this path
never you know especially yeah yeah but
when you get to be the best at what you
do other people gravitate towards you
like that that's that's what's
incredible man can you speak a different
language and even chatri or Mark
Zuckerberg think about that yeah well
also just martial arts in general like
it doesn't matter what country you're
from in the world it brings us all
together and connects us and I feel like
that's what one Championship is doing
being so about the whole world not just
one country yeah people from the U.S
could connect with people from Asia
people from no matter where you are it
brings us all together where'd you grow
up I grew up in New Jersey and and
what's your nationality Italian you're
Italian yeah no [__] think of his last
name yeah exactly last name I don't know
I figure it's like no you're not
croatians
I apologize guys there was some
immigration there but you know I'm
Italian so that you're Italian also my
mother's 100 Sicilian oh Sicilian my
family's Sicilian also we're in Jersey
um Central New Jersey Monmouth County I
know Monmouth County you're from New
Jersey what town Marlboro I know
Marlboro my my wife is from Morristown
really Cherry Hill I've been down there
a lot oh my God and then are you still
doing uh are you only eating uh once a
day still yeah once at eight people
once a day Pizza Pizza yeah it's pizza
every day and are you claiming New
Jersey as the best pizzas or not uh I
think New York Brooklyn my family's from
Brooklyn we got some people I'm biased
we got some pizza Talia is good been all
over talia's good pizza legit Pizza New
Jersey uh
um Frankie Edgar's coach Mark Henry has
a Jitsu uh he he's Frank Yeager's head
coach but I think it's called Pinos is
it Pinos Chen but he has a pizza joint
that he owns some of the best pizza I've
ever heard you sent me like you were
literally and then Frankie Edgar yes
Mark Henry runs Sal's Pizza it's
freaking fantastic amazing Pizza uh but
I can't go there when I'm in New Jersey
again the tie to Mark Henry is when I
was getting ready for Merkel Crow cop he
I trained with him he came up with the
game plan to beat murko wow he was the
whole Mastermind behind it yeah I was
terrified but um
I love him hope he has no ill will I
absolutely but uh uh also in New Jersey
Frankie Edgar took me to Jersey Shore
and had amazing Pizza there he says the
water he says there's something in the
water yeah water but you know your your
favorite uh uh Pizza Joint since your
pizza
Brooklyn
oh this is my question you're so
powerful you've changed every city goes
to no I know that's what's crazy you
shame me but um you you're a guy who's
got this crazy you've done this
incredible thing you went from eating a
meal a day you have all the money now
you don't need any money do you live
different like what do you do for
extravagance I'm always curious
um so this kind of kind of
sound kind of weird I still eat one meal
a day it's come full circle but I do it
for different reasons now it's
intermittent fasting it's the whole you
know uh so I don't know for me literally
the the best part of my day every day is
training whether it's Muay Thai Jiu
Jitsu literally I don't have so your
life I don't have
other Hobbies I don't have material
things I I just I own one Toyota that's
it like I don't I don't I love you I
just don't I'd rather have amazing
friendships they're awesome have
incredible experiences do wild crazy fun
stuff like this right here surreal stuff
you know like I never even dude when I
was sitting in in sleeping my in my in
my dorm room on the floor my mom's in
the bed did I ever think I'd be like no
doing what so it's just life is a crazy
adventure if you just take risks if you
do if you open yourself up to it right
open up and I always tell them I could
open up to like the signs there's like
this random signs in the universe and I
don't sound like crazy guy but but I do
believe that there are random things
that happen and then you it's it's
whether you you follow those things or
whether you're just like no no no
Society tells me no I'm not allowed to
do this I got to do this right I gotta
have a nine to five job I gotta stay at
Showtime because blah blah blah blah I'm
making too much money it's too it's too
safe but there's signs that say that
tell you your inner voice says hey bro
yeah and are you do you listen to that
or you do not right so I have that
saying my my best self is always
clearing his throat in the other room
you know and you can just you can like
ignore that but he's always like hey I'm
over here and you know you can do this
or stay safe yeah and it never it never
ends the thing about full circle it's
like even signing DJ and now you're
breaking ground in Denver it's like I
mean and it could be DJ's last fight
yeah it's like all this stuffing up yeah
Mike is a co-main event a jiu jitsu kid
it's not how did you like you started
this thing but when did you kind of know
and feel it was what was the magic sauce
where you went this is gonna be
something so the first three years uh
were complete disaster like literally
complete I was losing Millions uh barely
on TV and like at two two a.m like you
know some small and you start it from
the jump I started from scratch from
like a little piece of paper a business
plan like let me write it down let me
start this thing and it was just me and
I said okay I'm gonna do this thing and
and uh and I'll tell you so I would go
around across Asia to different
broadcasters like the NBC or whatever
CBS equivalents or ESPN equivalents and
I'm telling you I would go and have to
meet the junior program manager of the
junior program manager and I'd meet and
just because no one would meet me like
who the hell are this guy yeah so I go
and I'm like talking to some 25 year old
kid who's responsible for like you know
the 3am slot uh and but he's gonna ask
his boss to fill the dreams yeah so I'm
having to come that's not my journey so
I got rejected by everybody thousands of
rejections failures then I went to
governments and said hey I want to throw
this event and I'm doing some martial
arts and they're like you're a [__]
here to get out of here and then and the
same thing was you know for for um
investors and and and and athletes
thought I was just stupid why would why
why would I do this you know everybody
hears this chapter when you started I
started in 2011 end of yeah and did you
ever want to give up did you ever almost
give up yeah at the end of three years
it was 2014.
and I called my conservative Japanese
mom
and she was very against this idea
because before uh one I was on Wall
Street with I had a five I owned a 500
million dollar Global hedge fund that
was my my are you your account you're
already killed no no no no no so that
was my job before it was my own firm
and when I was leaving Wall Street
because I was like Mama I'm not happy I
want to go do something right with my
life and she's like oh you're being
arrogant you know you forgot your your
days in poverty and just because you're
making a lot of money meanwhile I know
my mom she's very conservative Japanese
today she loves the fact that I was in a
suit and a tie and a nice office we
should be safe and it's like oh it's a
global history my my son is our hedge
fund manager
um and so she's always against it so I
call her and say mom
um
you know I I'm just getting my ass
kicked and I think I'm gonna quit
and my mom I thought she was gonna tell
me no no no she said oh yeah why don't
you just quit good idea quit
and
I talk for a few more minutes and I hang
up and I'm like this is so weird my mom
just let me quit then I started thinking
about why did I start this thing well
it's my greatest passion in life you
know I want to show the beauty of
martial arts I want to I want to bring
the world's best martial arts together
to showcase the whole the whole world I
want to tell their stories I want to
inspire Humanity you know martial has
changed my life I know it can change
other people's lives
um
and then I just said there's no way I
can quit and now when I look back on it
my mom was using tips on reverse
psychology she wanted me to like so I'll
never expect people to go yeah just
quick yeah yeah so so I was like I was
really pissed
but that I used it and then and then so
this is crazy so we had a few months
left of cash on the balance and I said
and if you chart the history of one
our rise on our viewership numbers and
you chart the history of social media
usage and you chart the history of smart
mobile devices okay yeah think about the
last 11 years
the rise of the iPhone all over the
world and and and first time it was 2007
I think no no but I'm saying momentum
right
yeah Global penetration then social
media think about Facebook's numbers
from 2011 to the day okay I think back
then there are a few hundred million
users and now it's 2 billion three
billion right
that rise is exactly and and I always
say man I don't know how other sports
properties did it because
we put out a piece of content and it
goes right all over the world and so you
get thousands of fans around the world
and ten thousand hundred thousands of
fans and you keep on putting out these
in Crazy Muay Thai Kos or whatever it is
right Mikey ripping a leg yes yeah
ripping a leg off I mean so Mikey's very
I'll give examples so the most watched
fights in in Jiu Jitsu okay before one
we're like Gordon Ryan or Roger Gracie
getting and they get one to two million
views Mikey's very first match in one
against iminari okay who's an MMA Legend
they did only grappling went 125 million
organic what it went ballistic all over
the world okay
my point was when I I said to my team
we're running out of cash I said I don't
think I'm going to fund any more of this
is my my own money and my best friend's
money I met with hundreds of investors
they said that was stupid broadcasters I
was stupid brand said I was stupid
everybody said I was just because there
was already something that was that way
no no there's because Asians don't need
a sports property we already have on TV
we have F1 we have NBA we have English
Premier League we have Champions League
there's no it makes no sense it's
impossible and plus how are you going to
pull this off it's impossible how are
you going to get the best athletes in
the world you don't even have anything
you don't even broadcast you're you're
at 2 A.M on Two on Two in two countries
there's a void there right because
Pride's gone or leaving at that time
probably gone bankrupt uh uh several
years earlier yes so there was a
quote-unquote void why did I go bankrupt
that's a difference
and then and then the authorities
clamped on oh got it yeah so so a long
shortcut short
um that was our strategy was like let's
upload videos onto Facebook book of cool
Kos of cool stories inspirational life
stories whatever it is of our athletes
and it then the numbers start going off
and they literally went vertical okay
our organic video views and our
followership then I would go to a
broadcast and say hey Mr broadcaster
take a look at these numbers what are
these numbers okay these are our numbers
on social media
would you like some of that juice on
your yeah right so then like okay well
you know what we'll put you at midnight
and we did well on midnight and then I
said okay why don't you put us 11. today
we're live Prime Time 179 countries
every Friday every Saturday Friday every
Friday okay so we have more number of
events you have in your roster
several hundred damn yeah yeah but
um and you know I'll give you example
like in Thailand where I'm from we're on
the biggest broadcaster that has a 50
audience share
we're the number one rated show of all
content sets of all genres news
entertainment soap operas movies TV
whatever it is sports everything we're
the number one by far by far okay and
that that Journey
of going from you know two countries
with saying three a.m in the morning
whatever it is to now us being in Prime
Time live across age on the biggest
platforms okay like in in China One 10
cent in Japan TV which is the largest
digital TV player in Japan 80 million
subscribers
um out of a country of 120 million
people and uh we dominate we just
somehow now like but that whole journey
was thousands of rejections a lot of
luck and of course I I love I love
martial arts so that's if I didn't love
marketing if I was doing it for money
yeah I would have quit yes because there
was an honesty there man because because
there's no there was no money I'm like
dude am I crazy was this a move it's a
movie dude they're gonna make a movie
hey Amazon well what are we doing it
might be the event itself and May 5th is
when it's when it's happening you got
some monsters on there yeah that's gonna
be exciting so excited
you're throwing it down yeah yeah with
my Mikey shorts so you know so sure so
everybody we've that that's ever come to
our to our shows right so I'll give you
example Eddie Bravo
so so I invite Eddie to Singapore
um because I wanted
um selfishly the 10th Planet system in
evolved my chain of Martial schools
because I wanted to learn some 10 Planet
stuff this is like you know right yeah
yeah exactly so so Eddie comes like hey
Eddie I actually have this other company
one you you want to come join my show
and it goes first and he says
his first he was in all the whole show
and he goes chatri I've been to hundreds
of events from other organizations best
this is the best I've ever seen the
production value the the Everything is
Everything I've never seen it and I was
obviously super super happy I'm stoked I
mean man that thanks bro
um and uh so that's why it's awesome too
that Eddie's coming to to our debut in
the US as well you know he's a good
buddy I like him I like him that's
exciting and uh this is going to be this
is going to have a huge effect on the
MMA world like in the United States it's
going to have a big effect on Sports in
general yeah because because how happy
Amazon has to be stoked yeah no no they
they are super happy with their numbers
um we we've blown away all their
internal expectations when they first
signed us like you know it's on I'm
sorry to interrupt but it's on Amazon
Amazon Prime for free live and free wow
and they have 200 million subscribers
right so it's like literally damn we got
to Rally the whole nation to to come
watch us and and blow up the numbers
that's what I would love man that's what
I would love my specials on Amazon
no
um that that's that's That's so exciting
because I want to see now because it
feels like there is a competitive
uh player in the marketplace for
Fighters and
it feels like it will be a better thing
for all fighters if the UFC has
somewhere for their stars to go when
their contracts are up so they can use
it as leverage I don't want to get too
you know touchy about this because it's
dicey but wouldn't you say there's that
but it's also like they're they don't
need the UFC fighters to be successful
what I'm saying is the fighters
in UFC the fighters themselves need it's
a good thing that one is here because
there's another player in town where
they can go you know I mean look at
Francis there you go like Francis isn't
old no and now he's out there looking
for the right fit and we've had France
on the show many times I love Francis
news agent Markel very well
um my I would call Francisco well what
else would you do though where else can
you go where they're going to allow you
to box and then compete in mixed martial
arts and be a heavyweight champion both
where else she gonna go love to hear it
name another spot Francis yeah and
that's why that's you know again because
I'm a lifelong martial I want to create
the home of martial arts and we really
had that's one thing I'm most proud of
is like look we've created a platform
for the you know the best martial arts
on the planet but they can choose pick
and choose what they how they want to
craft it or who they want to become what
they want to do if you want to just be a
pure Jujitsu guys no worries no that
that's great too but we want the very
best in the world but if you want to be
a judicious guy and now we want to
dabble an MMA uh actually we're going to
also do a DJ versus uh Mikey grappling
match
ES
yeah damn yeah
it's competing against Rod tank yeah
yeah first yeah check this out so it's
Mighty Mouse right I know you don't know
who wrote you have to educate yourself
on yeah but he's like a crazy Muay Thai
monster oh bro monster maybe they go to
Muay Thai now what's that maybe the goat
in Muay Thai now really oh the best
you've ever seen his highlights are
stupid stupid but what they did in the
fight with Mighty Mouse the super fights
first round was Muay Thai second round
was MMA so Mighty Mouse is like if I can
just survive and get out of this first
round that second round get hold of his
neck which he did yeah how big is uh
rotang same size same size
because I remember book how my buddy
Frank wrote the thing with bukow yeah uh
for fight world and he was just hanging
out with Boca for a week and he was like
like the the celebrity yeah yeah yeah
otherworldly Mike I'm sure in all Jiu
Jitsu guys they see you doing the thing
and one video has 175 million views yeah
for Jitsu just to get exposure's tough
definitely it's like you Gordon Ryan
there's a few other outliers out there
but other than that tough to get
recognition especially mainstream so
you're doing one Championship I can't
imagine how many guys you're inspiring
to try and get to that level but again
as chatri said they're only signing the
best of the best so the the chances to
get the one Championship to get to your
level I don't think people realize like
you're talking about less than one
percent are ever going to make well we
came from competing in high school
gymnasiums in Jiu Jitsu you know and now
we're like in front of millions of
viewers hundreds of millions of viewers
you'd never wrestled in high school you
never did anything I did I did a little
wrestling as a kid but then I was in the
adult class in jiu and I can't wrestle
adults when you're a little kid so yeah
then I beat I became a guard guy and
what were you what do your parents think
of it now they see on TV they're like
holy so my parents always pushed me to
be a doctor or lawyer and then once this
happened with one Championship they like
finally respect this career you know
yeah
I'm gonna be a Grappler mom yeah hold on
no you're not
you know
it's it's funny how when you follow your
bliss
it the answers all the answers lie over
there somewhere maybe because it's yeah
it's like a Magic Door if you have the
guts to go fall to to maybe it may make
no sense yes to anybody yeah anybody but
you just do it and you just do it secret
sauce is here absolutely out of all I
think you're right
I'm telling you yeah the secrets you
were saying that before he's not saying
this to you now he was saying this we
were talking on the phone about it and
he was saying that so here's some
current events Chad sure they'll be
mainly MMA related but current events
like whatever's trending in the fight
world
goodness white shirt who said that it's
rare you wear white I know so the
pay-per-view numbers for javonti Davis
and Ryan Garcia pay-per-view and the
gate damn
they just came in and uh I I think this
puts them fifth as highest gate ever I
think uh Manny and Floyd number one
Connor and Floyd number two they beat
the Canelo Mayweather fight oh wow
did you guys watch this fight do you
follow other sports yeah yeah yeah yeah
but I only watched The Big boxing fights
and and I definitely you know obviously
was very intrigued by by this fight
um but the outcome I kind of thought
would be what the outcome ended up being
I think top tough fight for foreign
exactly I love Ryan and you know I
thought it was interesting just
especially in your box and it's like we
don't get the fights that the fans want
to see because of so many different
[__] it's insane so hats off to both
these guys even though Ryan lost like oh
dude don't he's a close buddy I don't be
down man what you did for boxing yeah
you're setting a path and a trend
hopefully these other guys like Crawford
and Earl Spence follow yeah like give us
the fights we want to see that's what's
wrong with boxing yep yep 100 yeah good
for them yeah what else you got Jim uh
so Joe's showing remember he went viral
for that
street fight thing yeah so because he
was in Florida just a little background
if you guys seen it so he was in Florida
he was at like a bar and this guy was oh
I I remember this and he was knocking
him out right yeah this guy this guy's
being a piece of [__] all night this was
a vicious knockout this guy was causing
problems all night and then Flinch like
talked trash
yes right I don't remember yeah he was
using the n-word oh wow watch this watch
this look and then he flinches it
so that guy tried to sue Joe Schilling
and which is outrageous but they but
Florida Florida led him off because he
had to go to a trial let him off for the
right to protect yourself oh wow
Joe that's so great yeah that's our guy
and people told him just settle because
it's going to be a nightmare but he
would not settle good for him finally
yeah he won the case basically
uh good for him man
I've seen people what do you think and
of course an ideas is next what are
people going to learn not to mess with
these guys it's like it's like you got
to poke the bear why not just poke the
bear and see what happens well there you
go it's because they've never had a guy
like Mikey grab him I think you're
arrested you're 25 Mikey 26 26 have you
had any issues on the streets well I
didn't monetize the kid so I know it's
Muay Thai yeah I only had one fight as a
kid I was in camp at like six years old
I just kicked the kid in the leg and he
fell down crying that makes sense six
years old that's fine but and I assume
you're not like a bar guy like you don't
know you don't seem like buying boxes
there are a lot of track marks it's just
a lot of shooting now yeah alleys but
they're too high to fight what's this uh
chin so you know Nate was in like two
different scuffles and then uh so there
was a warrant for his arrest so he just
turned he voluntarily went in you know
did Bond and now he's out but yeah this
is my thing with Nate like at his level
and his Fame like he has the money
higher security get a bodyguard like
you're too famous yeah yeah
Target yeah correct all right people
know they want to show you for right
there you go instigate something so that
they can sue you and in America that's
what they do it might be that Nate runs
with a rough crowd too
part of the problem though because his
crowd they like that atmosphere but you
need security so they can escalate it
because it's gonna cost you more money
yeah some of the guys he runs with are
rough push-up and covers you can't have
that no if his level you can't have that
but at least he didn't put in Jeopardy
of the Jake Paul fight thoughts on like
Jake Paul and Logan Paul doing what
they're doing yeah I know I look for me
I just uh I don't know why people hate
on them I think you know they're
entrepreneurs at the end of the day
correct and they're able to capitalize
and and they understand pop culture
really well and how to hit the right
buttons and I think you know kudos to
them and and here's the thing about Jake
he truly loves boxing you can see it
yeah he's not like okay let me I'm a
YouTuber let me just you know monetize
my YouTube by about you know he is a
boxer he loves it I was saying that
somebody he's different than his
brothers brother he's kind of and I love
both of them but Logan's little you know
who do WWE and he'll do this and his
prime drink and he'll do like the Floyd
fight and the just the big fights with
Jakes he's down for them
you could see yeah he he loves it and
and man if he had started boxing when he
when he was you know five years old he
the thing is he started when he's like
20 something like yes it's hard to start
a professional sport and be the best in
the world
um if you sort of late age you know I
started when he was four yeah exactly
Mikey's been training 12 hours a day
since he's four how are you gonna
compete with that there's not enough
hours in the day yeah
you're about there were total twins
wanting uh team match versus Gordon Ryan
and Garrett Tony wow when did they say
that I didn't know that was that today
oh it's April 28th yeah we would do it
we would do it I mean I mean uh you have
them under contract correct yes I mean
Gordon we we uh released amicably
um because what happened was we'd signed
him and then he got his um stomach
issues yeah and then he actually retired
because he thought it was going to be
permanent right then covet hit and then
you know I didn't tell him we're coming
to the U.S yet and he said chatri I'd
like to when his stomach issues cleared
out after a couple years then he's like
um you know I'd like to compete can I go
on I think it was flow or something at
the time and I you know
um I didn't want to stop him I said okay
sure you know so we so I said that we
just let you go and that's it
um it worked out for both of you yeah
yeah
so uh so so Gordon and I have a good
relationship great guy uh yeah we we
talk uh you know uh periodically quite
regularly whatever on Instagram Etc
um and he's a good guy he he
um yeah he's always been you know good
to one now
um I'd love love to see uh that matchup
that'd be amazing but I'd also like to
see Gordon versus Ty you know yeah
there's a little bit of heat between
them you know yeah yeah for sure yeah a
little bit of heat are they the same
size no no no no Gordon's like 2 20.
large that's a large size difference
yeah yeah yeah yeah and at that skill
level that said that's that's a serious
Advantage yeah yeah yeah sure but if it
but it would be like no different than
an absolute division right yeah it
happens a lot of times you can grapple
right it happens all the time and that's
the thing with he's fought if you go to
YouTube I think he one guy he thought
was 240 220 no 400 pounds
it's getting ridiculous right did you
sub him no I won my point you did win
yes so 135 pounder versus 400 pounder I
mean is this crazy did he even see you
he probably wasn't able to see you did
you have a piece of chalk to keep there
it is where there it is on YouTube My
Team versus a big guy
oh my God look at him look at him
well he's so big that's hilarious
I don't even know yes oh that's it grab
those ankles big guy got that he's just
a bear
but you see because Jiu Jitsu you could
be on the ground Size Doesn't Matter as
much because gravity yep yep yep when
you're standing with wrestling Muay Thai
uh size matter so much big time yes but
now you're bringing them down to your
level there you can make the person use
their weight against them
he's so big yeah huge I mean yeah dude I
heard that Tom Cruise on the set because
he's not a tall guy when there's a
meeting he does this
yeah do you want to get to his level I
would go no no
I'm just gonna say like a regular human
being you'll take a knee with him with
Mr Cruz you take me well he's like if
you want this part in Top Gun technique
yeah I might start doing that I don't
like you that you're so much taller what
else you got Jen I just wanted to get
Mikey's take on this
was it Gordon Ryan and uh not not this
one here well basically Gordon Ryan and
Nikki Rod I guess he Nikki Rod was like
uh no so people thought he was on
steroids Nikki rotten Gordon Ryan no
just Nick just Nikki does Gordon Ryan
openly admits he's on steroids but then
uh so Gordon didn't believe that Nikki's
not on steroids and he also accused
Nikki of Grayson or something like that
when they had a match but uh so there's
a guy from more plates more dates Derek
yeah he randomly tested Nikki Ron he
apparently like clean the cleanest could
be we randomly tested him for a long
time too okay yeah yeah how do you feel
about that Mike you like obviously those
guys are different than you they're
they're bigger monsters yeah you know so
it's just a different game I feel like
99 of people in Jitsu on steroids
unfortunately yeah yeah that's a large
number and I mean yeah yeah that's why I
really respect the rotolos and myself
because even though we knew everyone
were gonna fight his on steroids we
never took steroids and we still beat
them all you know
um I feel like you're not on steroids
you look like you're Jews to the game
yeah
please keep going if by Pizza you mean
steroids yeah I just feel like
um everyone looks for shortcuts and
there are no shortcuts in life and we
have to like work hard regardless of
what other people are doing you know and
also one Championship test athletes for
steroids so that's why I love one
Championship especially for that reason
for jiu jitsu like we could start
changing the platform from 99 people
Beyond storage to now people won't be
like okay they have to take starts
because they're going to test people
right yeah when your answer has changed
in a lot of ways the the fight game
because you look at even the weighing
system so you know like the way in guys
can't completely deplete their body so
they have an advantage and just
rehydrate do you know the weighing
system for one Champion they have a
hydration yes I love that I love it
because it's so much safer for the
fighters I feel but how do you do you
keep you you test them during the week
during during fight week you you test
their water how much water is in their
system and they're so they're not
sucking water weight like last two days
right right and you you can just see it
through and then obviously
um the day before the fight you you can
see and then we weigh them after the
fight as well man that's that's but I
think that's why you're getting a good
result and your high finish rates too
because yeah I agree because you you get
uh and I was talking to Roberta about
this and Roberta's chatri like I feel
incredible I've never felt this way you
know because you didn't have to cut so
much water weight I mean during fight
week he was like this is unbelievable I
just never you know this was in his
debut fight in the Philippines and uh a
lot of athletes say that it's like they
just feel like they're on point
I feel like as a fighter an athlete like
long term we have to think about our
bodies and when we're in like that
second we don't really care about the
future of our bodies yes like so that's
why athletes will take steroids but the
long-term effects of steroids on your
body cutting all this weight all the
effects on your kidneys like one
Championship is kind of protecting us
from that and that's amazing why'd you
arrive at that was
um you know I so I've been very lucky
that we have an incredible team so I
can't I can't um give myself credit it's
it's a team like what I did say to the
team to our medical doctors
um we actually have in-house you know
hire a few doctors but also um we have
Matt Hume and it's so there's a lot of
real deep deep experience
um in fight Sports and I said go find
out what does the NBA do F1 what is what
do all these top sports properties do
for medical protocol safety
etc etc and I want to be better than
them what does UFC do I want to be
better than it that's literally I told
them yeah and so they spent the first
few years like like going after and
studying everything and I said come up
with a solution that's the best and that
so that uh is is the Genesis of it but
everything is so so even the global rule
set I said what I for example the
three-point uh the three uh the
three-point um on the mat
what does that rule so
you can't you can't be somebody right
correct correct so then you would see
the gamification again
right so there's a lot of weird rules
and even the twelves and nine elbows
perfect for 12 to six elbows is actually
not dangerous okay but because of the
WWE kind of pal driver thing like this
the State athletic Commissions in the
early days when the rules were being
formulated by with UFC in the nine right
yeah they saw people breaking bricks and
Boards yeah oh yeah that hits a human
skull it's gonna kill him yeah they make
sense they've never updated yeah yeah
never updated yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
insane so so wow so we allowed 12-6 uh
uh elbows as an example because actually
again me as a striker as a Muay Thai uh
practitioner I know which is the most
dangerous this is not dangerous this is
not because you're not you you can't use
your the torque you can use your hip
yeah no no but I'm saying even a short
elbow right you can your hips that's
what gives up and the fact it's a short
range weapon but here I can only use my
arm yeah right now of course I'm a pile
driving and jumping up and then elbow
this but in that's not gonna happen real
fast no you're not getting the tour you
never thought
but so so the the point is that there's
a lot of there's a lot of things that
are just kind of status quo and there's
no
um Rhyme or Reason yeah and I told old
way of things so I told our team just
let's make this let's revolutionize
everything even our Jiu Jitsu is
revolutionize okay so we have one
10-minute round sub only but it's also
based on real submission attempts it
can't be a fake submission attempt like
so a lot of these um organizations will
have like if it ends up in a draw
um whoever had the most submissions so
you have a lot of sloppy like uh
submissions that look like they're just
together just again right but we have
the thing called catch it has to be
locked out so the arm bars got to be
fully extended and that would be okay
and and the you know the legs in place
and hips up that is called the catch
okay or or if it's a rear naked choke
and it's on and it's on like it's not
just like oh I almost got no it's on
under your chin so somebody gets that
that's it and they get out of it it's a
catch yes and that's worth a point right
and then and then if the if it's if it's
a tie ball game whoever gets the last
catch wins the match so down if it's
there's 10 seconds left you're not going
to just stall because you're like it's
you know if if you have to try to finish
it you're gonna go because if this guy
gets a catch on me then then I'll lose a
match so you're you're fighting all the
way through for the 10 minutes and
there's always Concepts so if I'm ahead
I've got you caught you I've caught I've
hit you a bunch and stuff like that no
no no this catch thing is for the uh
are there three judges yes okay same
thing yeah same thing um
but but that criteria was that they
released objective scorecard I'm so
sorry
but we always said there should be like
maybe five judges right don't you think
or no I I don't think the number of
Judges matter I think I think the
qualifications of the judges matter
exactly and else experience yes you see
the the problem that you have in at
least
um what I've seen in in the U.S right
and remember I'm I love America's one of
the greatest countries I'm not knocking
it I'm just saying some refs and and
judges like they have never even done a
day of martial arts so how are they
supposed to judge somebody I've never
understood like do you remember most of
them have a box but even boxing
because it was like I remember like
several years ago I don't remember this
one of the judges said uh or refs I
don't remember said oh leg kicks don't
matter I'm like do you remember that
like I don't know yeah you've never been
kicked in the leg because let me tell
you that those things are think about
even a technical standpoint when the
fight goes to the ground and like let's
say Mikey was doing MMA in America in
the UFC Europe Bellator and he's
throwing just these six submissions the
guys constantly defending him those no
points no score they're not educated on
it even if they're trying to finish the
person insane insane yeah let's just say
the game One's Gonna Change so I think
every aspect of the game of the fight
game you know we're constantly trying to
innovate and improve that that that's so
there's never ever gonna be static and I
think that's also why we have a 70
finish rate so we're always trying to
figure out ways
um that wait this rule is that rule or
this or this this way why is it that way
and then is that is that the right way
to do it and but what's crazy to me it's
like we're having this conversation it's
like when you hear this like oh I can't
believe it's it wasn't like that always
yeah like these are easy things it's not
you know the things make sense it's like
yeah that's how it should be yeah I
remember the Genesis of UFC it was so
hard it was called human [__] fighting
so they had to make so many concessions
to be palatable yeah they're they're too
old
I have I have an immense amount of
respect to uh for UFC and Dana yeah for
doing what they did with the athletic
commissions right without their passion
and their grit and their resilience yes
yeah for sure because then he did and
then he did slap by league and went
three steps back yeah
I just died
you got to give credit where credit is
doing and and back in those days you're
absolutely right you had Senators saying
it's human cockfighting yeah how are we
gonna so if so would they say 12 no no
12-6 elbows okay fine I'll just you know
whatever it takes whatever you got you
gotta pick your battles if they're gonna
prove it and just put just do it right
yeah so I think they were at that point
but now that now that you know the sport
of Combat Sports any genre is widely
accepted worldwide it's like well let's
create the very best system that that's
the safest for athletes long term but
also the same time that promotes the
best action yes right and actually
finishes our safest right because you
like if you look just look at boxing
okay when boxers die it's never because
of the one punch KO it's always because
they've been in 12 rounds and they got
hit a few hundred times yeah and it's
the last round where they're exhausted
that they're dehydrated from that brains
and then and then they you know do you
know what that one of the through lines
to boxer's dying is I I read this I
don't know if it's true I'll have to
look it up but it made sense one of the
uh if you look at this there's one
factor there's one through line one
factor to boxers dying in the rank do
you see if you can guess what it is it
was kind of fascinating to me if what
there's one factor of why they died why
did I obviously it's not the one
knockout one knockout punch it's it's
it's it's it's the repetition what do
you think what do you think they all
have in common they got punched good not
bad any other brain Busters what do you
think it is
you think they'd be more lenient to
throw it's there it's it's a lot of
times the corner man's your father and
you don't want to disappoint him your
brother you don't want to disappoint
them so it's it's that love and that's
it that's 100 what it is it's like I'm
not giving up damn I know and uh kind of
makes you sad man it's kind of a crazy
thing but it's but it's about funny if
you just see one we send it on a sad
note we're gonna do what a great time to
be with you guys and and obviously no
surrounding right but I was driving here
so fast
you know no I'm so excited please tune
in show support the fight Goes Down May
5th it's live on Amazon Prime and then
it's also in my hometown in Denver Mikey
We're Not Gonna train after this I'm so
excited I can't wait to roll around yeah
let's train stay with my ankles my neck
and my elbows do not give Brian Mike
Zuckerberg cell phone please don't do
that Mike you can give me my experience
his evil brother yes Mark is that a tune
you want more you're good uh we're good
okay yeah that's what you have a good
one it's a pretty damn good one okay
let's see it we don't want to leave you
hanging all right be honest I can't
pronounce his last name back on the
wizard let's go his response to a
reporter oh this is great so Giannis he
could win MVP he'll be top three he's
he's been MVP before seriously would you
say yeah so in the NBA right but um so
he his team was favored to go to the
championship they won last year and they
lost in the first round the reporter
asked them uh is the season of failure
and his response is fantastic hit it
chin
what the hell no sign though
I will freak out it's just on the audio
you got hit at the bottom yeah outside
it might be copyright now oh man I can
do a YouTube though
there it is yeah and that's the image
that's about the exact same question but
I'm curious for you do you view this
season as a failure
oh my God uh
okay because I'm not that up
you asked me the same question last year
Eric okay uh do you get do you get the
promotion every year on your job no
right so every year you work is a
failure yes or no no every every year
you work you work towards something two
years ago right which is to get a
promotion to be able to uh take care of
your family to be able I don't know
um provide the house for them or take
care of your parents you work two years
ago it's not a failure it's steps to
success you know
wow I don't want to I don't want to make
a person so there's always steps to it
you know
um Michael Jordan played 15 years won
six Championship the other nine years
was a failure
wow brilliant
I'm actually a question yes or no
okay exactly so why you ask me a
question I've never heard a guy with a
Greek accent like that there's no
failure in sports he has to score 38
points well there's food days bad days
some days yeah brilliant man not good I
love it
so this is your turn so this is not your
turn and that's what sport is about you
don't always win I love it
and this year somebody else is going to
win similar that we're going to come
back next year try to be better try to
build good habits
yeah it's a good way to end this thing
cool [__] fellas can't thank you
enough you guys are inspirational oh
thank you so much man appreciate it I
see both of you guys in Denver
definitely my gonna be shouting dude I'm
sound like a group
watching good luck fellas you appreciate
it thanks for coming on thank you so
much for you guys thanks
Global phenomenon
born in the East arrives in the West
for the first time ever the home of
martial arts one Championship will be
live in the United States and in his
home country defending His World
Championship the greatest of all time
Demetrius Johnson one Fight Night 10
Johnson versus Mariah's three on Prime
video